as we near the end of pride month the
Gestapo of Seattle decided to kick
things up a notch for the last weekend
of this Unholy season by bicycling
completely nude in front of a crowd that
included children
pal of mine in Los Angeles texted me
over the weekend to mention that he had
the dubious distinction of seeing a nude
lgbtb the second B of course standing
for bicycle display as well and in New
York drag queens marched to inform
citizens that they are coming for our
children
[Music]
shopping
now the libs will continue to insist
that the degenerates in that video have
no particular interest in children that
they are not groomers
but they obviously do have an interest
in children and they're telling us that
they do and they have an interest in
children because their ideology demands
it I'm Michael Knowles this the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show really wild
clip over the weekend of the proud boys
possibly getting into a fight with
federal agents masquerading as right
Wingers we'll get into all the
implications of this in a moment first
though we're just gonna jump right into
the deep end today
we're here we're queer we're coming for
your children
the sexual revolutionaries
have an overt interest in children a
sexual interest in children it is
undeniable it is grooming it's nothing
particularly new it's been going on
since the beginning of the sexual
revolution in fact when you look back to
the 1960s at Old essays from Bernie
Sanders young socialist Bernie Sanders
he was writing about the need to
sexualize Children you can see it in two
essays in the Vermont Freeman why is
this you can see this in in other
writers beloved of the left people like
Wilhelm Reich and many others why why
does and now up to today you've got
these groomers in the schools and
dancing through the streets of New York
saying we're here work we're dressed up
in sexual Garb in a sexual demonstration
talking about a sexual interest in
children why is it is it just because
they're perverts
no it actually isn't
because you know the the live rejoinder
to this is always going to be like well
there was some Baptist preacher
somewhere and he had a sexual interest
in children or well there was some
Republican somewhere and he had a sexual
interest in children yeah there are
perverts everywhere not going to deny
that for one second
but for the sexual revolutionaries for
the pride people it goes further
into an overt ideological sexual
interest in children
the ideology demands it because the
ideology says that sexual expression is
good in and of itself
that's what the libs believe that's what
the pride people believe the
conservatives don't believe that I'm a
Catholic I think that there is all sorts
of sexual expression that's very very
bad I think there's all sorts of sexual
expression that's bad not just for
children but for teenagers and adults
and older people and married people for
that matter I think they're all that
sexuality is a very uh tempestuous sort
of thing we've got to rein it in and
control it and proscribe all sorts of
behaviors that is the view of
conservative people
for the libs though their moral
framework is if it feels good do it
and so like with the transgender issue
when you say okay if transgenderism is
true for a 25 year old if a man can
really be a woman then why wouldn't it
be true for a five-year-old if that's
the way human nature works then it's
true for everybody the same goes for
this sexual ethic on the left if sexual
expression is always good then why
wouldn't it be good for children now you
might say or a lib trying to defend
himself against these charges might say
well you've got the matter of consent
children can't consent but the libs
can't make that argument when they're
simultaneously arguing that a
five-year-old can consent to chop his
genitals off or to take cross-ex
hormones or to permanently sterilize
himself or to become a eunuch by the way
kids can't consent to anything
so parents make the decisions for
children kids can't don't want to eat
their broccoli the parents say you're
going to eat your broccoli kids don't
want to do their homework the parents
say you're going to do your homework
that's what raising children is you're
making decisions on behalf of children
that you think are in their best
interest and when it comes to the sexual
Revolution
they believe that it is in the best
interest of people to express their
sexual desires no matter what they are
because otherwise we'll be really
repressive and that'll give people a
complex and it'll harm them and that's
why we've got to protect trans kids and
the way we protect trans kids is by
sterilizing them or by putting them on
puberty blockers or by chopping off
their genitals or by encouraging
disordered sexual behaviors and desires
that's why they're always going to come
for your kids
that's why it's always going to end up
with that drag March in New York City
put aside the personal perversions of
these people
that is what the ideology demands
a little side note to the story the
nation's first self-identified
transgender state representative was
just arrested on child pornography but
we don't even need so you know okay
there you have it there's that's the
first one I'm just reading the news
story I'm not making any broad claims
but you don't you don't need to point to
that because then the Liberals will say
well there was a pedophile priest or
there was a republican yeah again I know
they're perverts everywhere but what
does the ideology say where is it overt
when people tell you what they want when
people tell you who they are you should
very often believe them
so where does that leave us now we're at
the end of pride month
Bud Light destroyed Target
partially destroyed people are turning
against this stuff they don't like to
see people marching the street saying
we're going to come and sexualize your
children so
Yingling is one of the companies
that is profited from this as Bud Light
was destroyed
Yingling Double Down
and said we're not going to push weird
sexual ideologies on kids
then people started buying Yingling more
now though Yingling was caught
sponsoring a pride event
yeah the story here from the daily wire
Yingling Brewery was sponsoring the
Music Fest drag show
uh at Music Fest Cafe
on June 30th and the Music Fest drag
show was was going to allow anyone over
the age of 13 to attend and so Yingling
recognizing that it's on the verge of
getting Bud lighted it's on the verge of
losing all the benefits that it got from
swooping in when Bud Light went full
Pride
Yingling is saying okay we need to raise
the age or we're going to pull out of
the event so now that the minimum age is
18 and that's good that's better than
allowing 13 year olds to go to these
events but Yingling should take this
further Yingling should just pull out of
the event people are sick of Pride okay
we've been very tolerant for a very long
time Will and Grace aired in the late
90s and everyone got very tolerant we
all like our gay friends we all like our
gay cousin but
this has gone way too far and everybody
knows it and so the pendulum is swing
back way in the other direction you saw
it in Gallup polling the approval for
same-sex relations of any kind has
dropped precipitously it's something
like seven points in just one year there
is absolutely no commercial or political
benefit to Yingling Brewing Company
which has already identified itself as
an enemy of the rainbow flag there is no
benefit to Yingling sponsoring a drag
show for anybody of any age 18 plus
included okay I'm not saying Yingling
needs to go out there and you know start
embracing Sharia law or something like
that okay we can be very very tolerant
very very nice and love everybody and
not not send the morality police to
people's homes without sponsoring this
public deeply unpopular degeneracy okay
nobody nobody who is buying Yuengling
beer wants to see a drag show just ditch
it guys you can go we can go a lot
further conservatives suffer from a
failure of imagination very often the
libs never suffer from that
it's helped them politically for a long
time so when the political order is
breaking down
you're probably going to want to protect
yourself and your assets you might want
to check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 as central banks in
countries such as China India and
Australia begin transitioning to digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
a digital currency the government could
track every single purchase you make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products or easily
freeze or seize part or all of your
money Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold they are the
people that I trust for gold I'm very
pleased to have some Birch gold and
thousands of other people are very happy
about that too Birch gold will help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into an
IRA in Gold you don't have to pay a
penny out of pocket when currencies fail
gold is a safe haven how much more time
does the Dollar have protect your
savings with gold Birch gold has an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers text
nulls
to 98 98 98 get your free info kit on
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend on text Knowles
kwles to 9898 98
you're seeing this same thing with
Starbucks here Starbucks Workers United
the Starbucks Union is calling for a
strike because Starbucks allegedly
discouraged shops from putting up
rainbow decorations during pride month
and I hope that's true I hope Starbucks
Corporation did that however Starbucks
Corporation then came out and denied
this allegation said no we stand with
the LGB LMNOP community and still it's
not good enough for the Starbucks
workers so the Starbucks Workers United
are calling for a strike of over 150
stores and 3 500 workers Starbucks
should fire as many of these people as
possible you know I have long defended
Starbucks even though it's got a little
bit of a woke reputation I've said these
guys have done a lot of good I think the
coffee tastes pretty good as far as
mass-produced coffee goes I think
they've installed public bathrooms in
every major city in the world which is a
great benefit to society I think that
it's just a well-run corporation they've
started putting Christmas back on the
cups again in December they don't put
the the employees are very often pretty
woke but the corporation doesn't peddle
that stuff don't cave to these guys do
not cave to them it will not benefit you
it is not 2005 anymore Pride ideology is
not on the rise they jump the shark
they're translating the kids everyone
hates it don't cave Starbucks don't cave
if you're listening to the show speaking
of uprisings
you may have heard that there was almost
a Civil War in Russia over the weekend
and I'll give you the the broad Strokes
of it as though I were some kind of
expert on Russian Politics as though
anybody were an expert on Russian
politics uh the the Wagner group the
fancy people called the Wagner group The
Americans call it the Wagner group the
Wagner group is this paramilitary in
Russia and the leader of the Wagner
group is this guy progosian who is just
a psycho-russian warlord and pagosian
was very upset because he felt that the
Russian defense minister shoigu was
undermining his position and even
killing some of his mercenary troops so
pregosian decides to march on Moscow he
got within a couple of hours of the
Kremlin and or at least with a couple
hours of the outskirts of Moscow and
then he halted there was an 11th Hour
deal he turned around now precaution has
been exiled to Belarus which means he's
probably going to be awaiting the
delivery of a nice polonium tea any day
now you know one of Vlad The impaler's
Messengers is probably going come and
end his Consciousness but uh this was a
big threat to vlad's power
and the question is did we know about it
did we instigate this sort of thing uh
in the initial report said U.S
intelligence agencies caught flat-footed
here taken by surprise by the Wagner
group Uprising in Russia then later on
we had reports that said that U.S intel
was aware of this beforehand and you
know they were monitoring the situation
and we don't know what to believe
because some people believe that the CIA
controls every single event in the world
and it's it's the most powerful body on
Earth other people believe that the CIA
and the U.S Intel agencies are basically
incompetent and
I think it might be a little bit of both
you know the CIA does have a lot of
power they've amassed a lot of power
over the years also it's a government
agency and the federal government is
sometimes bumbling I think of that great
Cohen Brothers movie Burn After Reading
the the point of which is that events
just continue to spiral out of control
and the CIA is often the cause of that
but they they never seem to make it any
better and so they say okay we'll just
keep just keep your eyes on it keep
monitoring it and they'll try to play
catch up afterward regardless this would
appear to be a tactical win for NATO
because you've weakened Russia here
you've weakened Putin without totally
destabilizing the country and so this
raises another point this is the point I
want to talk about nobody really cares
about the internal politics of Russia
I care about how this plays out in the
media and what it means for Americans
and those of us in the west which is
there sure were a lot of Russia experts
over the weekend there sure were a lot
of people
there was a liberal establishment
that was cheering on the coup d'etat
by this guy pragosian
and I thought
what do you think is going to happen
what do you I know that
the American liberals have they just buy
whatever the Western propaganda feeds
them and whatever the Washington Post
and CNN say is the the current thing
we're all supposed to just become
obsessed with that and buy whatever
talking points they feed to us
but
do we really want Putin gone
what what happens if we kick out Putin
what who takes over
do you know not you I'm preaching to the
choir but the libs who were cheering the
sun who do you know do you know the
names of five Russians other than
Vladimir Putin liberals I don't think so
I don't think they know anybody involved
here
I I think that they just are have been
programmed to believe Vladimir Putin bad
Vladimir Putin new Hitler get rid we
must get rid of Vladimir Putin okay so
now you're cheering on some complete
psycho Russian warlord with a private
military marching on the Kremlin to take
control of the nuclear weapons of the
former superpower that's what that's how
much the Washington Post has melted your
brain
do you think that's a good thing have
you lost your freaking mind
why what how does it benefit us
to get rid of Vladimir Putin
who yes despite being in all sorts of
nasty guy
is a relatively stable
moderate Force
by the standards of Russia and extreme
politics we really want nuclear weapons
in a country that could fall into Civil
War I don't think so and we got it
sometimes we got to just take a break
turn off the CNN close up the Washington
Post for a second take a look at the
situation and say okay and this is true
by the way of social media this is true
of so much of our emotional response to
politics when you're feeling like you
really just you're getting angry maybe
you even feel like you hate somebody in
politics that Trump he's the devil is
Hitler or are you that man okay take a
pause
just say hey what
why do I hate him
how did I come to hate this guy Trump is
a great example for this this is a guy
who was a fairly beloved celebrity for
40 years and was the host of the most
popular game show on network television
and was
adulated in 300 plus hip-hop songs
and then just one day
as though the liberal establishment
unscrewed the back of our heads opened
it up pulled out the computer chip that
said you like Trump and put in the
computer chip that said you hate Trump
Trump lovable Trump funny Trump fund
celebrity oh we're gonna pull that ship
out we're gonna put in the Trump evil
Hitler chip Boop and then all of a
sudden on the dime everyone turned when
you feel your emotion just stirred up
like that you got to just take a pause
ask yourself not whether or not this
person is good you can get to that
question later ask yourself first
why am I being told to hate this person
what strategic goal is Advanced here
speaking of unpopular leaders Chris
Christie
he's on the campaign Trail Chris
Christie running for president Chris
Christie was just booed
by an audience political audience for
dissing Donald Trump
all right we heard the reaction to your
speech at the faith and freedom
conference I assume you well knew you
were going to get booed when you started
slamming Donald Trump's leadership I did
hear some Applause in the crowd as well
but the booze were loud what what's your
saying say is the anti-trump message is
there any evidence that it's resonating
absolutely evidence is resonating
Jonathan in the in the race for less
than three weeks and I'm already in
third place in New Hampshire only four
points behind Ron DeSantis who's been in
the race for a longer time and is
supposed to be the co-front runner uh
look
um people understand that folks need to
take responsibility for what they do and
my message to the folks at Faith and
freedom which did get some good reaction
too but of course I expected the booze
that is predominantly a trump crowd but
they need to hear the truth too
they need to hear the truth too okay now
you know and I know this has been so
unpopular an opinion for me to say
all right you want to talk about Chris
Christie getting booed when he knows
he's gonna I have I have had a very
unpopular message for a long time but
I've stuck by it because I'm here to
tell you the truth folks and my message
is Chris Christie could have a moment in
this race everybody laughed at Chris
Christie they said he'd never get above
one percent I said he's going to have a
moment if I could bet on him unpredicted
I'd probably put at least a small amount
of money on it
because I'm not saying he's going to go
the distance I'm not recommending that
anybody put their money on Chris
Christie but
I I feel he's got a lot more political
skill than others are letting on and so
he's saying
I go to Faith and freedom I go there I
give an anti-trump message I get booed
but I'm doing well in New Hampshire this
is a really
important insight for the 2024 race
the Christies of the race
are having a little bit of a moment
Trump is remaining dominant
what is the takeaway here the takeaway
is not that you're going to be rewarded
for attacking Trump the takeaway is not
that the path to the nomination is
attacking Trump
the takeaway here is that the supposed
co-front Runner Ron DeSantis is
weaker than it seems there's a pullout
from NBC News you know about the
chrysosons I've talked to you about the
potential criticons right now Trump is
at 51 percent
DeSantis is at 22 percent
Pence is at six percent Christie's right
behind it five percent Haley at four
percent Tim Scott three percent of
vacant three percent even ASA Hutchinson
at two percent
how how has the movement been on those
numbers Trump is up five points from
April Pence is up one point Christie is
up Five Points as I told you would
happen
the big change here is DeSantis is down
nine percent Chris Christie is not
taking votes from Donald Trump Chris
Christie is taking votes from Ron
DeSantis
because as I've said from the beginning
the big trouble for Ron DeSantis is that
he is running in the Trump Lane he is
the Trump candidate his pitches on Trump
2.0 I'm Trump without the weaknesses
but his big base of support is going to
come from people who don't really like
Trump all that much and so he's he's got
to be both the better Trump and the
anti-trump and that's a very difficult
potentially impossible line to walk
the people who really really want Trump
they're just going to go for Trump
Trump's in the race they're going to go
for the OG so how does Rhonda santis
prevent himself from from watching his
support just dissipate between Trump on
the one hand and the Christies and the
other candidates on the other
when you want to solve thorny difficult
problems like this you need a good
education when you want an education you
got to check out Grand Canyon University
right now head on over to gcu.edu I love
Grand Canyon University Grand Canyon
University is one of the first schools
that I ever visited when I was on my
college speaking tour I've been to
dozens and dozens of schools and GCU I
love I now work with two of the students
who brought me to GCU that first time
one of them here at the daily wire one
over the young Americas Foundation it's
just a great place and with everything
on your plate earning your degree online
might seem impossible well Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life whether you are a busy
professional looking to advance your
career or a stay-at-home parent juggling
family responsibilities gcu's online
courses give you the flexibility that
you need to learn on your own terms
Grand Canyon University specializes in
helping you fit your bachelor's Master's
or doctoral degree into your busy day
from scholarships my scheduling your
graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed so why wait
huh you're ready to take your education
to the next level you need Grand Canyon
University find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University that is gcu.edu
gcu.edu
Chris Christie's big charge here in the
race is that Donald Trump he is just not
fit to be president
character is the single most important
element of a president of the United
States because you can't know every uh
every issue is going to come across a
president's desk it's not a litmus test
with check boxes are in them what you
need to know is what is the character of
that person and frankly when I I
listened to Donald Trump's speech last
night and he had the audacity to say
that he got indicted for us
now I don't know how it benefited the
American people for him to take highly
sensitive intelligence and secret
documents out of the White House to
Stonewall the government on returning
them for over a year and a half to
subject himself to a raid by the FBI
even though they had asked to
voluntarily to return this stuff
um and
um to then be subject to an indictment
which is obviously going to be one of
great trouble for the country because no
one wants to see this happen it's not
about whether you think Donald Trump has
been treated fairly or Not by the media
or by elements of the justice department
it is about whether he is a man of
character who can lead this party to
Victory and I don't believe he can
I don't believe that Donald Trump has
the character
to be president that line doesn't work
anymore that line might have worked in
2016. and you might still say well Trump
doesn't have an admirable character I
don't like his character okay but you
can't say Trump doesn't have the
character to be president because Trump
was president and he was a good
president
he got Roe v Wade overturned he was
great on foreign policy he was great on
immigration until he was undermined by
his bureaucrats but for that the first
little bit of his administration was
very good on on immigration immigration
fell dramatically the economy improved
you can't say that this is an argument
from what is it uh heraclitus I think
said a man's character is his fate and
this was the art big argument against
Trump in 2016. he doesn't have the
character to be president but he he does
and so you've just taken a major quiver
that you could use against Trump that's
gone and that's why the Christie
argument is not really hurting Trump
Trump's numbers
generally are just going up or staying
the same
the argument Christy is
also as predicted Christy is going to
weaken the non-trump candidates in the
race defuse some of that support and now
you are seeing a situation and we're
just seeing the beginning of it anything
could change but you're seeing a
situation that is beginning to resemble
a situation like Trump had in 2016 and
2016. Trump just had a solid plurality
in lots of states and the rest of the
support was split up among the other
candidates and Trump took the nomination
now in this case
using Trump according to symbols with an
outright majority so it would seem even
better for him what is
what is Trump's message Trump also spoke
at this conference faith and freedom his
message was an unusual one for the GOP
the world is on fire this world is on
fire
the horrible war between Russia and
Ukraine totally settled I'll have it
done in 24 hours
to some of the things that I'd get that
done in 24 hours I know them both I know
them both
as the Bible says blessed are the
peacemakers see that I will be your and
I will be your Peacemaker I was your
Peacemaker
this is a very conservative message
and it's also a very unusual message for
the last
30 years I guess of the GOP
certainly the last 20 years the GOP
message has been a little more
saber-rattling
there's been a little bit more we're
going to go in there we're going to bomb
them we're going to spread Freedom
around the world you're with us or
against us we're gonna go attack the
axis of Evil spread democracy wipe out
these different bad guys around the
world Trump is saying I'm going to be
your Peacemaker blessed are the
peacemakers I'm going to be a peacemaker
in politics
as you're seeing the Democrats become
more and more belligerent Joe Biden's
foreign policy is just more war that's
what it is
and he's fairly open about that
he has prolonged the war in Ukraine he
in many ways instigated the war in
Ukraine those aren't just my words
that's flat Vladimir zielinski who said
that if Biden hadn't pulled the
sanctions off of Russia and if by
obviously Biden hadn't invited Russia to
invade actually said if it's just a
minor incursion into Ukraine we won't
really do anything about it that you
wouldn't have seen the war in Ukraine
but the but the Biden foreign policy is
let's have more war and let's manage
more Wars around the world the Trump
message is
no war I'm going to be your Peacemaker
he broke the mold okay and so even if
you come later and you say I agree with
that Trump message and I'm going to
implement that drum message and let's
say you actually can let's say you're a
candidate who who is somehow able to
implement implement the Trump message
better than Trump is it doesn't really
matter
because
if you like that Trump breaking the mold
thing you're probably you're probably
going to go and stick with your guy
stick with the original now speaking of
hearkening back to better times
it's an important new poll on the
culture which is that Americans want to
unplug
Americans who often are very bullish on
technology and they want more technology
they want more gadgets and gizmos
they're turning away from that just as
they're turning away from the rainbow
ideology they're turning away from
technology a new poll is found at 77
percent of middle-aged Americans between
35 and 54 years old want to return to a
time before Society was always plugged
in a time before the internet was always
on and cell phones were always in our
pockets and we were always expected to
answer texts and emails and it's not
just middle-aged people
this poll from Harris found that 63
percent of people aged 18 to 34 so now
we're talking about Zoomers as well as
millennials also want to go back to
simpler times even though a lot of those
people especially the Zoomers never even
experienced that I remember when we got
our first computer in my house I
remember certainly remember when we got
the internet for the first time
certainly room I didn't have high speed
internet until I was
17 or 18.
I I vividly I remember I remember a time
before a computer in the home and a lot
of younger Millennials and Zoomers can't
say that but even though a lot of them
can't remember it they say I want to go
back to that time
once again fewer Baby Boomers want to go
back to that time 60 of people older
than 55 say they want to return to those
pre-internet days this Maps almost
exactly onto the pride survey that that
Gallup found which is that in terms of
people's views on the pride ideology
younger people are much more likely to
want to roll it back much less likely to
support the Rainbow Coalition in fact
the only group that is getting more
socially liberal is the Boomers
the younger guys much more traditional
much more conservative and overall
two-thirds of poll respondents say they
prefer things as they used to be versus
what they are now so what do what do
these guys want
and by these guys I include myself in it
I don't I don't live on my phone I'm
probably on Twitter too often but I
don't do the other apps I don't I'm
rarely rarely on Instagram I'm never on
Tick Tock I've never answered my texts
almost never I don't like it I don't
want the new gadgets I just find it so
distracting it's exhausting even when
you catch yourself Doom scrolling it
doesn't make you feel better depresses
people it's just
so no bueno it's no good we're getting
sucked into this Black Mirror what are
people really yearning for here
one people are beginning to question
the progressive view of History The Whig
view of history that history is always
getting better in the old times were
terrible and the modern time is always a
crisis and the future is always going to
be much better that that's over I I got
in trouble among the libs a couple of
weeks ago because I I said I don't want
to follow the results of this new Social
Survey and return to the social
conservatism of 2012 I want to return to
the social conservatism of 1220 and the
libs made fun of me for this but I don't
know why they did a lot of people agree
with that
in order to agree with that kind of a
sentiment I'm not saying I want to
return to the Dentistry of 12 20. that
sounds unpleasant but I do want to
return to some of the social
conservatism the unity of family the
confidence of in faith and civilization
the recognition of a moral order the not
having bands of lunatics marching down
the screen screaming we're here we're
queer we're coming for your children I'd
like to return to that
to the seriousness of philosophy
I'd like to return to all of that and I
bet a lot of other people do too what
what the people really are yearning for
the ones who say
that we're now less supportive of the
pride Coalition or we're now less
supportive of technology and being
plugged in all the time what they really
want is a return to control and virtue
and they find that our society which is
increasingly liberal and technological
is taking away control
the the technocrats in Washington DC and
elsewhere in the world are taking
control away from us our technology is
taking control away from us our
technology is spying on us all the time
collecting data serving Us ads they
think that they know us better than we
know ourselves very often that's true
and we're living in a liberal society
that mocks the very concept of virtue
for all of human history until
liberalism until the Modern Age Society
was understood that states are ordered
toward the good that we want more good
stuff and less bad stuff that's the
basic basic idea of statecraft and then
modernity comes in and liberalism comes
in and makes fun of that idea and says
with a radical skepticism they say we
can't really ever know anything about
what's good we can't really ever know
anything about virtue so we're just
going to make everyone rich materially
we're going to give everyone gizmos and
gadgets which is fine I guess it's nice
to have material wealth of course but if
that undermines The Virtuous basis of
society then even as your Society gets
materially much much richer you're
you're simultaneously going to see
increasing rates of anxiety depression
suicide you're going to see plummeting
rates of marriage you're going to see
plummeting rates of childbirth you're
going to see
exactly what we're seeing right now
who is more risible who is more worthy
of mockery
the people who say maybe we should learn
some lessons from the past and try to
reinstitute those ideas into society
including and especially Western
Civilization at its height Christendom
at its height or the people who say oh
everything's going great now yeah where
do I where do I plug my neck into the
Matrix give me my goggles I want to eat
the bugs and live in the Pod I don't
think so I don't think so
now speaking of this supposed progress
this report came out daily wire
exclusive the University of Virginia
trans Clinic
is admitting something that we
conservatives have been worrying about
for a long time and we were called
conspiracy theorists for saying it and
we were censored for saying it and we're
going to say it anyway
daily wire has has seen waivers from a
top Virginia Clinic
UVA Medical Center
that requires parents to acknowledge a
[Music]
maybe we should articulate a different
view a more traditional view of what's
good and push that
want to know about something that's good
Jeremy's razors introducing for you the
Precision five razor one handle plus one
blade cartridge kit four
what would you pay for that a hundred
dollars
85 what if I told you
14.99 Jeremy's lowest cost for a razor
and only for a limited time
crafted with a luxurious tungsten handle
five welded steel blades and a flip back
trimmer for a close smooth shave around
hairlines and hard to reach places
remember though the Precision 5 is no
ordinary razor it's a sword in the
battle for beliefs a banner to wave into
a new economy a Precision instrument to
force woke companies to earn back your
dollar and stop denigrating your beliefs
but it is also still a razor and will
give you a great shave the Precision 5
is starting at 14.99 with the price so
low it has never been easier to stop
giving your money to woke corporations
that hate your guts join Over 125 000
men who have ditched their woke razors
and switched to Jeremy's never a better
time or Price go to jeremy'sraisers.com
today
my favorite comment yesterday it's from
thumper84 who says was just at Walmart
saw Bud Light 15 packs for 16.48 with a
15 rebate it's devastating it goes on to
say the display was completely full yeah
of course you talk talk about the
waivers about the potential side effects
you know you go to the UVA trans Clinic
it could render you sterile forever
think about the side effects of drinking
even just one Bud Light
could you imagine sort of thing could
ruin your marriage sort of thing could
ruin your ability to have children
now speaking of
incoherent liberal priorities
do you remember
it's about a year ago maybe even over a
year ago
Texas governor Greg Abbott along with
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis some other
Republican leaders decide to send
illegal aliens out of their states to
Liberal strongholds Governor DeSantis
famously sent the illegal aliens to
Martha's Vineyard which was hilarious
Governor Abbott though he got a little
less publicity for it but he was sending
the illegal aliens to places like
Chicago into places like New York and at
the time
here is what New York City liberal
Democrat mayor Eric Adams had to say
about a political leader shipping
illegal aliens to other states away
from their cities and states
this is horrific when you think about
what the governor is doing the governor
of Texas
after a month of traveling across the
border placing on the bus with no
direction to come here uh to New York
and New York is a city that has always
represented the democratic values and
the values of our city of showing our
compassion and that's what we're doing
today that's what we're doing today this
is horrific
to ship illegal aliens just because you
don't want them in your state in your
city you're going to just ship them out
of there
pass the buck
outrageous
until
mayor Adams just got caught doing
exactly the same thing actually not
exactly the same thing he is shipping
the illegal aliens to other states
he's shipped them to over a dozen states
he's also shipping them to other
countries
Eric Adams so it's horrific to send
illegal aliens from Texas to New York
he's shipping them to it to over a dozen
other states and to five countries
including China
Venezuela Colombia Peru
and Ecuador
awful awful when a republican does
something
wonderful when a Democrat does the same
or a more egregious version of the very
same thing
I'm not going to say I'm not going to
even bring up if the shoe were on the
other foot you know that's the Epitaph
on The Headstone of conservatism imagine
if the rules were reversed
just pointing out that when when the
Liberals make these arguments this is
horrific violation of Human Rights how
could you ever see they don't really
mean it
they're just lying and using that
political issue as a cudgel to beat the
Republicans into submission and The Rock
ribbed conservatives see through this I
strongly suspect
there are plenty of liberals who listen
to this show I'm pleased to say but the
people who are listening to this show if
they're not rock group conservatives
they're at least independent thinkers
who see through a lot of this piffle but
there were people the squishes in the
Republican Party
and the centrists and the people and who
just want to be liked by The Washington
Post in the New York Times they're the
ones who will join the chorus of the
Eric Adams's who say well you know
that's really awful you know actually
that's really awful to do that to those
illegal aliens we shouldn't do we're
better than that
no it's a that's a Perfectly Natural and
just response to foreign aliens in your
country in your country or in your
municipality illegally it is Perfectly
Natural and right and just to ship those
people out of there
they just don't want us to do it because
Mass migration is in large part a
political operation to undermine the
political and electoral viability of
Republicans throughout the United States
that's why the libs did it that's why
the libs continue to do it and when the
caught when they have to bear the costs
of that the housing and the taxes when
they have to bear the political costs of
that which is even Democrat people in
Democrat cities don't want to have to
pay for this stuff then they will
sometimes ship them away and they'll
ship them back to the Republican states
very often so that they don't have to
deal with it speaking of Federal issues
one of the funniest videos I've seen in
a long time
over the weekend goes viral this is
proud boys met by a group I think called
Patriot front it's hard to tell exactly
who these people are because they wear
masks over their faces and this is a
group
as we in recent months maybe a year
you've seen this group Patriot front
come to the fore and they March and they
seem really on the nose and I think I've
never really heard of this group and I'm
pretty in it you know it's my job to
read about what's going on politically
in the United States especially on the
right I don't really know anything about
these guys it seems kind of like a well
it's right there in the name it seems
kind of like a front you know it's we
know that federal agents infiltrate
these supposedly right-wing Grassroots
groups we've seen the memoranda from the
FBI we've seen these guys get caught do
you remember at the justice for January
6th rally where pretty much no one
showed up other than journalists and
federal agents there was this famous
picture taken of guys who are obviously
feds they're all wearing the same
brandless clothing that they've all got
the same haircut they probably got done
at Langley or at the FBI headquarters
they're all wearing the same Shades
they're all checking their five and
they're six and they're seven it was
just they're all wearing the same Garmin
watch it was such a joke and what's
funny now by the way is if you Google
this picture if you look for it on
Google you won't turn up if you look for
it on Twitter it won't turn up you can
say justice for January 6th rally feds
j6 feds whatever it doesn't show up you
can't find it I need to go to Bing to
find that picture even though that
picture was everywhere at the time so we
know that this kind of stuff happens and
there's a video
of The Proud boys going up to these
supposed American neo-nazis and saying
get the hell out of here you guys are
not part of us you're obviously feds go
away
[Music]
see the guy in like the mullet proud boy
waving the American flag going up to
these
supposed American Nazis saying get out
of here we don't want you here you're
obviously just infiltrator pack shills
go away
[Music]
and they do
back them off
they do all these guys who very
conveniently are covered up in their
Shades and their face masks they get out
of here and some of the proud boys then
tried to I think unmask them and it
created a whole issue now look I don't
know if those guys are feds I don't know
if those guys are there just to try to
make the right look batters I really I
don't know I don't I don't know I don't
really care however there is one good
piece of evidence
that these guys might have I'm not
saying that they're actual employees of
the federal government that they might
have some kind of connection you know to
the federal government one piece of
evidence here
that that their feds is from Adam
kinzinger former Republican member of
Congress who's a total Shale for the
liberal establishment he tweets out he
says these people
referring to conservative pundits who
were laughing about this video
these people all blue checks are
celebrating a seemingly Maga assault on
federal officers now I don't know what
this really is but take a gander at the
comments of the patriots who love
America
and reading that comment you say hold on
wait
you're admitting that Patriot front is a
bunch of feds did you Adam kinzinger who
is not the swiftest politician out there
that's why he's no longer in congress
not necessarily the sharpest hole in the
Jed
he's out there he's saying this was
outrageous all these conservatives are
laughing at an attack
he's like no man you're supposed to
pretend that they're not federal agents
and anyway just a reminder
that
the you really shouldn't believe
everything you read in the liberal
establishment papers because the reality
what's going on on the right is not the
way that it is portrayed and I think
people are beginning to wake up to this
and you're seeing it reflected in the
polls and priorities of the real
conservatives okay today's music Monday
baby and I'm finally I had a crazy week
I was traveling all over the country
last week I'm back here
in Nashville Tennessee it's music Monday
and I've got my trusty iPad so I'll be
chatting with you
the rest of the show continues now go to
dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knolls and check out
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign